on the first of September last year
farmers department store Wranglers
anchor store in the High Street was
reopened twice its predecessor in size
this was a signal of confidence in the
town and a celebration of recovery and
regeneration led by the council with
strong support of business and property
owners although the regular town seemed
to largely survive the initial
earthquakes ongoing shaking and tougher
National Building Standards lead to a
large number of closures even for stores
and relatively unaffected buildings the
loss of foot traffic spelled tough times
ahead ironically council a few days
before the earthquake had signed off on
a long term strategy for the town center
it was built on the framework for local
economic development strategy and the
principles of business friendliness
articulated at the time by local
government New Zealand by employing a
dedicated approach to business support
which included planning the provision of
infrastructure regulatory activities and
social and community facilities we
created an environment conducive to
sustainable economic growth even in the
face of disaster the RTC 2020 strategy
provided the framework for recovery
which included temporary business
accommodation which we literally
provided on the front lawn outside of
our offices if the council hadn't
stepped in to help us fiercely secure
the premises temporarily and secondly
give us a medium-term option while while
the pharmacy was rebuilt on its old site
we possibly would have had to go out of
business instead we were able to keep
trading the north of high precinct plan
which involved a new public laneway and
redevelopment far beyond what could have
been achieved by private parties or
council acting independently i thought
they've done remarkably well it actually
trying to go for a good outcome given
all the factors going on rather than
just going for the quick outcome I think
that's been really important
our strategy also plan for a complete
upgrade of the public space along High
Street we worked closely with owners to
ensure that all buildings including our
own community facilities were upgraded
to at least 67% of the revised building
code but perhaps most symbolic of all
was the 12 million dollar strengthening
and expansion of the Town Hall the new
building complete with cinema and
meeting facilities was a statement of
the confidence we had in the future of
the regular town center the town's
absolutely buzzing the vibrancy both
during the daytime and with the amount
of restaurants what opening now the
nighttime as well the town has really
catalyzed however this is a tale of two
town centres and cryopod just ten
kilometers down the road was even more
badly affected the youth Craig
ultimately destroyed 40% of the town
centers retail space the Main Street was
cordoned off and patrolled by the
military and over 1,000 homes were
eventually redesigned
not only was stores shut but the
shoppers were moving away and the very
future of the town center was at risk in
response we undertook a two-year program
to support businesses and fast track the
town's recovery they were great anything
we've had queries on they got Oxford out
very quickly and they helped fast-track
plans through so we get up and running
as quickly as possible in very difficult
circumstances our initiative included
accelerated development and 2011 of the
KTC plan for the reestablishment of the
town center a complete upgrade and
beautification of kiya boys William
Street partnering with private owners to
strengthen or replace buildings and a
complete replacement of our badly
damaged library and service centre the
13.5 million dollar ruetten a
psychiatrist civic centre has won
numerous awards and incorporates a
museum in an art space
we've had a whole reinvention of the
town center if you like and it's looking
fantastic
the result is a practical demonstration
of a build back better approach to
economic development with council
working alongside business and
developers to solve shared problems as
we plan for the next five to ten years
now more than ever we value the
comprehensive local government New
Zealand framework that is proven it's
worth is our district flourishes post
quakes and we embody our vision to make
Waimakariri
a great place to be in partnership with
our communities
you